Oh welcome to this video its qui [ __ ]
again if i remember correctly it so I'm
always playing 90 of three year let's
see I don't remember exactly what I did
again sir let's stay solid with the
Queens gambit no we are not playing the
Queens gambit ok now let's let's go be
solid and develop John if you go Knight
c3 in d4 d5 openings I think you should
at least be flexible with your f porn
this looks very um yeah very harmless
let's say I mean of course that's not
bad for white just that it doesn't feel
particularly threatening so c5 maybe
let's prepare that night b5 was a bit a
bit of an annoyance so yeah I don't want
to take he might take with the sea pawn
yeah attack the center you're going for
a form I don't think that it is very
threatening okay I can take this
opportunity now to change the pawn
structure that looks quite solid like a
queen's gambit it's a queen's gambit
exchange structure cards but structure
with some trades and wear black will try
to play on the queenside night to see
form something like that it's very
standard like rook c8 9594 yeah at least
I was quick so ah she wants to go to e3
it seems okay maybe I can try to
irritate them a little bit there well
you can still certainly cannot go there
because be too okay maybe I cannot take
be to immediately but um yeah anyway
that looks fine in my book for black in
my book as a matter the figure of speech
yeah I don't have stuff like that in my
head my name's iboga book so um now I
still don't see so don't see him playing
93 as I take be too
does he want to go like g4 yes in here
is go in g for okay yeah g for the idea
was to drive the night back and then go
97 forking but not see for some just in
time yeah if it takes on c4 that seems
likely it's an interesting question i
can also take with the pawn okay really
okay
I can pre move 94 in both cases I will
play them threatening almost f6 okay I'm
not really threatening f6 if he takes it
pawn takes it still has Luke h5 so I
don't trap the rook yeah that's a
strange move but maybe not as bad as it
looks okay again or four possible night
c4 I don't really see him doing anything
on the edge file I mean maybe maybe but
he has to play some prep moves for that
yeah that's interesting and let let me
try to trade Queens I think that would
be helpful and maybe maybe like
something like if five was interesting
okay yeah it doesn't really matter until
I still think that I can be happy i'm
not claiming anything special but it is
a it is an ok position ready
yep he's got that potential come to play
with f5 so is that how dangerous is that
is a dangerous
not quite sure
but I can take it twice the question is
really is that is it is it that is it a
problem if I am but just take it twice
okay now he prepares it they also
preparing like rogue f2 I see
interesting yeah that's probably okay
for him/her that counterplay is hitting
just about at the right moment so
hmm yeah i think it's probably probably
about equal
and I played it well that n kim was
really who are played gras our third hmm
I don't know is it a draw just want to
check i mean i got that passer on the HL
it's probably still draw I is a draw
objectively speaking can I try something
or am i risking more time warning I'm
trying something at least maybe maybe
that's it's a no it's a bad idea of it
in our kids difficult oh it's really
difficult to do something I will want to
try I ok no Jaquish this maybe go oh
wait I can go here maybe trying to
that's not working rooks is six if it
takes it now I have to do this for for
the negativity check so let's products
probably far too risky what I'm doing
here check check
I cannot go King g4 here unfortunately
that's bad anyway to continue your king
g form ok I can play the move oh it's
not playing she's just all the time I
also widened our heads on time yeah well
apply pre played on position here not on
time I really tried to do something with
the H point it was far too risky of
course and not really objectively good
check no yeah maybe I should take that
draw here now yeah I should check the
drawer it's probably not the worst
possible result he played that well from
one point I think here I'm in good shape
but probably queen bee five isn't a
great idea it's not I should probably
start with this move yeah that's
probably better but he has this idea of
counter play on the H file so it's not
that is without its chances he can do
something like this for example I have
to be alert well play something like
this um there's also in the right moment
this kind of idea or queen here and then
something on h7 not easy not easy at all
GM here we are talking about an equal
position I guess yeah I tried to tried
some things but it's questionable in 56
is so helpful actually maybe I should
play route 66 immediately now it's about
equal it really is ok well thanks for
watching